heis are you guys the Softworks nice to
see you again sir see you sir you're
here for her that's my guy I made the
hell right yeah we put it in the shot
and then it was too heavy to bring yours
let's go put it up instead yeah whooping
Stein the new order now playable on the
show for absolutely you guys have a big
old queue very long when I run finish
worth it and what give us the pitch for
folks who've not seen much of
Wolfenstein um hopefully everybody knows
Wolfenstein it basically invented
first-person shooters as a thing this is
a game that is sort of sticks with the
Canon of Wolfenstein but it's it's been
made by a some guys called machine games
and a large group of whom and were used
to do used to be at a different
developer and made games like Chronicles
of Riddick
and the darkness and are known for
taking action and combining in things
like story and character and trying to
have it be a bit more than just a
one-note thing and they really were
interested in taking Wolfenstein and
saying look we wanted to kind of do a
reboot like not not starting over from
the beginning but pushing it forward in
doing something else with it and adding
a lot to it like BJ doesn't mean
anything to anybody yes just he's just
the guy holding the gun that you're
pulling the trigger on so we want to we
want to explore like what is he like and
and they really like this alternate
universe idea of you start the game in
World War 2 BJ goes into a coma
it takes some shrapnel in the head goes
into a coma 14 years later he wakes up
to find the Nazis won the war and rule
the world don't you hate it when that
happened it's a nightmare
and and so it's really you and him and
going through this sort of man out of
time story where you're figuring out
what would the world be like in the
1960s if the Nazis ruled everything he's
got to find the resistance and start to
fight back because that's you know
that's all he knows it it's one of those
things where he's sort of at first blush
he's just like a big-headed guy who
likes to shoot Nazis but actually his
whole thing is like he just wants to go
home he just wants to go home and leave
a normal life and the only way to do
that is to kill all the Nazis and so
it's like that that's kind of what he
does and he's very good at it but
ultimately he just wants you know a wife
and kids and a white picket fence and so
it's it's a I think it's a really well
done thing at
hopefully you guys have seen some of the
trailers we just we just put one out
last week whose idea was it to have a
referee shooting soccer cause it
actually your idea like I mean look 14
years in Bethesda I finally got soccer
under one of our trailers yeah but we
like the idea of playing with the the
alternate reality and it looked Nazis
they're probably the easiest easily
hateable no need any context like what's
their motivation why why don't I like
them like Oh Nazis got it bullet head
let's go have you guys seen the most
recent trailer the one of those soccer
rough getting blasted no oh you're
missing out it's pretty bad running in
the booth come by and see it in the
booth because it has one of my favorite
things about this game and it's the
villains like you say Nazis you don't
need a reason to hate them but you guys
are really going out of your way to give
us a lot of specific people to hate
because they are crazy and creepy and
this dude general death said in the demo
like he he moves a little like Gollum
and he has this like skeletal like I
thought literally turned around it's
like started yeah just creepy looking
and not cool he's got he's got some
great he's got some great leg line from
the trailer I love like general deaths
head I don't like it I'm a happy man
like and he basically is just performing
awful human experiments so um yeah I
mean it goes back to the question before
about machine games and what are they
trying to do like it's about story and
character for them like yes you could
just make it about generic Nazis but
it's a lot more fun when you get to know
some of them and appreciate like you
hate them on a whole different level you
want to die you like a guy badly
that's a weird kind of it's like
interesting because wolf3d
no one was playing for the story no
we're like even Return to Castle but
like any one of these games they're just
there were blaster shooter games yep and
like how how do you guys try and have
like interesting characters thatwe don't
need on a story too much but also have
this like ridiculous gun warfare is the
last half of that trailer basically was
just like yeah all these ridiculous gun
yeah like double dual wielding double
automatic shotguns and like these crazy
Nazi weapons that you get your hands on
when you can like melt four dudes at
once it's it's that balance where they
wanted to sort of push the idea of the
shooter mechanic and make it fun and by
the way it's not just a shooter so
you know they've layered in all this
stuff where you can play it as a more
stealthy game in the game plays
differently like you can run into a room
guns blazing and take everybody out but
you can also move through and find
secret passages and get behind the enemy
and take out the commander so he can't
call in reinforcements there's a whole
perk system to the game so doing stuff
like this where you're stopping Nazi
States table instead of a Nazis in the
head but you start to unlock special
abilities the more you do this then you
learn new ways to do stealth takedowns
where instead of having to sneak up on
them you can throw a knife from a
distance and take down a guy down the
hallway instead of trying to make them
and there's different ones for that for
you know whether you want to be more
like demolition like explosion focused
or how you use your guns so it does
allow some variety it's not just a
one-note linear thing and I think again
the character and story stuff just adds
to that the guys that you're you're
fighting alongside the guys that you're
shooting you know at all it all fits
together to make a really cool
experience you can see here some of the
deformable terrain stuff where you're
blasting away with this day your
euphemism for a dude get his head blown
to bits if there were boats already I
was referring to the column but the head
is part of the deform terrain um but
yeah you know sitting it in an
environment where you feel sort of
powerful and cool and kicking ass
kicking ass is still fun I'm going to
throw that to the audience for a second
for some questions I wanna ask one more
in the meantime though AB so this is
single-player only seeing that there is
an association with first-person
shooters and especially games that have
any sort of like hi history with its
software of multiplayer like how you
guys tried to you know get over
perceptions audience I think for a lot
of other publishers that would probably
be a trickier question to answer but
Bethesda stands defiantly in support of
single-player stuff
fallout 3 Skyrim Dishonored evil within
Wolfenstein we believe if multiplayer
fits and it's part of what you're trying
to create you should absolutely do it
but if it's not for God's sake leave it
out stop shoehorning multiplayer in this
stuff that has no business being there
and ultimately machinegames knows
machinegames no singleplayer they and
this is the kind of game they wanted to
create and so we just never really had a
conversation about what do players like
alright that's not what you're making
then let's just make this the best thing
we can and that's what we're doing and I
I think there's plenty of folks who
still enjoy and appreciate you know a
nice good robust blast of us had a
player I'd never played it once but
that's the best money I spent last year
just playing that single player
experience and so I think this can be a
game in that vein cool I got any
questions out there we maybe get over
this side we've got the middle last time
yeah gonna make you run dudes at the
back I see you then I see your hands
wave them furiously we get a microphone
do we have the mic are debride I was
stand up there all this was standing
microphone oh yeah you just do that a
well-oiled machine
haven't you been to pax before there
wasn't standing microphone earlier these
big lights are in my face no um we got
all out there alright cool cool potato
mash room first question do it yeah
kinda looks like a potato masher is this
using its own game engine or is there a
shared game engine with any Bethesda or
it it's using a modified version of in
tech 5 so they took the existing it tech
stuff and did a whole bunch of stuff to
it because they wanted to do more things
with awesome dynamic lighting and and
Nazi texturing and things that didn't
support is this getting released in
Germany it is but in Germany they're
they have a thing about Nazis out there
are a little a little touchy don't know
if you know and so it they're called the
regime in Wolfenstein in Germany and
it's actually I'm pretty sure this is
the first Wolfenstein game that will
ever be released in Germany but it's
completely stripped of all the
constitutionally yes and content
I thought Return to Castle Wolfenstein
was released it
and they meant they said it was like a
germ warfare game it was or something
yeah but ya know it'll be released there
but it's a it's about a random made-up
loop of bad guys the baddies yeah they
know what it really is though who just
hoping to be Aryan featured and yeah and
I've drove an accident gross what is
going on go for it gross every question
that's des heads it's a single-player
only game what are some of things that
you're going to have us keep coming back
for besides maybe the multiple skill
trees or the weapons as a difficulty
sure it's a good question replayability
obviously is it is an important thing
extending what you're getting for your
money is something we're very well aware
of there's a couple of different things
we're doing one is a mode we're not
actually talking about yet although I'm
lobbying for us to talk about it soon
but there are there's a collectible
aspect in the game and once you play any
particular chapter you can go back and
replay it if you want to find the
collectibles you missed but if you find
all the collectibles you unlock this
cool new mode and when I actually
convince everybody to start talking
about it you'll be like that is super
cool and I want to find all the
collectibles just to try that mode
because it's not just a hey the game got
harder you played it earlier on the uber
mode and it's pretty yeah it's pretty
difficulty is not a thing we need more
of at this point we wanted to do
something different
but it was good like if I've started on
the fourth of five difficulty levels and
I felt like I was moving along like
alright you know I have to use cover
here but I felt comfortable but I didn't
want to feel comfortable so I kicked it
up and then I done got you're asking me
to I was doing a lot of time but I was
you know especially this scene when you
you know this stabbing happens and it's
wonderful but then like there's so many
other guys there that you have to try to
stab this is the point where BJ BJ is
waking up from his coma
yeah the Nazis are basically killing
everybody in this island where he's
being been kept and taken care of and
he's got to he's right now he's
basically fighting his way through and
trying to get back to Anja who is the
woman who's been taking care of him
oh yeah it's it's not easy that section
as stealthily as you can when you play
the game because once it gets loud or
just do that there's so many of them we
need murderers chop into the ice is also
highly effective yeah that's
kostik add three more questions lining
up to the microphone in their program
head sir
all right do it you just jump and say
your question again no oh man this was
like fit into the Canon with Wolfenstein
um but like I can kind of see that is
going for a more futuristic styling
where the last Wolfenstein game kind of
like went crazy with like the whole like
mystical stuff ecad disowning that
Activision won yeah so so the question
if you didn't hear it was basically the
last one did more of this mysticism
thing
this one is more focused on tech we sort
of went like this with the mysticism
stuff and just said look like the reason
the Nazis won the war is because they
have this amazing technology and that
technology is super advanced and allow
them to win the war in ways they
couldn't have otherwise so there's no
like moving between planes of existence
or stuff flow it's just it's a more
grounded realistic thing it's a it's
grittier like this is for me like I look
at this as like The Dark Knight reboot
of Wolfenstein where it's like it's it's
a little gritty er it's trying to be a
little bit more grounded and and I think
that that's a part of an important part
of it and as you go along you start to
figure out about the technology that
becomes an important part for the
resistance like where they get this
stuff can I have some too because I
would love to use it against them that
kind of thing right thanks that's a
great question I just in the mean time
it ended 0-0 that's they'll all to any
UK people in the Arsenal game so replay
fun go for it
um I just wanna know uh how hard was it
to like take a character like BJ
blaskowitz who's like he pretty much has
no emotions in the first couple games in
it like in all um actually it's part of
the face he goes oh yeah that's it oh
how hard is it to like humanize a
character like that where everybody's
just like I'm a guy I go around and I
murder everybody and that's my job it
does it's very good it's a very good
question actually I wish we had it it's
not in the b-roll but we said it
GameSpot might have it up we I think one
point we did a little side-by-side
comparison of obj and new BJ graphics
compared
like the 16 pixel you know it's like
just in case you've forgotten BJ he said
his head is about this big and this is
what he looked like and this is how he
looks in next-gen as far as the
personality that's a that's a tricky
line to walk because whenever you start
to characterize the person you're
playing it might not be the way you
envisioned yourself like we're starting
to to put more context to it as opposed
to letting you fill it in yourself like
it's an important thing we do a Skyrim
for example like you don't have a voice
like you you are who you ever you want
to be we're not we're not saying stuff
on your behalf but in Wolfenstein I
think the you know yen's and his team at
machine games Tommy and some of the
other guys in writing the dialogue and
so forth had a very specific balance
they were trying to fit where it's it's
one of those things I really think you
have to play the game to appreciate
because I think you can see some of this
stuff out of context like he's not he's
not averse to one-liners like goofy
eighties movie action one-liners but he
has this interesting thing like where he
never uses contractions like he's and
like he he speaks in sort of military
talk very effectively and then you also
hear some of his inner monologue stuff
where he's thinking stuff that just
doesn't sound like something that he
would he wouldn't necessarily say but
like it's just like a [ __ ] hate Nazis
but that's how people are like that's
like like sometimes you know what you
say outside is things like I just
[ __ ] hate Nazis but what he's
thinking inside is so much deeper and
more poetic than that and we know that's
inside of you you're given to any a lot
of credit right that's actually all
that's in here and the depth of my Nazi
hey I'm not gonna put it as you play the
game you kind of start to appreciate a
little bit like like where he's coming
from and what his motivation is and how
he thinks about stuff but then he still
has his funny little one-liners like I'm
coming for you you [ __ ] Nazi base man
and like you know it's funny when he
says it like that and then it's funny
when he when you hear the internal stuff
like I think he hits a good tone it's
it's really hard to do that stuff and
hit a hundred percent of your audience
somebody's gonna have an issue with
something but I personally like I love
it like every time I play the game he
still makes me laugh
I find his dialogue stuff really funny
still so hopefully you guys will enjoy
it as well this is one of those games
that if I get a chance to play it it's
like you know a bunch of people sitting
around with headsets on and I'm like
cackling or like talking [ __ ] to the
enemies or whatnot and I feel like I'm
the only one making a lot of noise in
that just a silent room and you guys are
watching and just like we are just like
crazy outbursts we're recording it
because we go back and watch those later
and it was actually you who said I
[ __ ] hate you you not see space Nazi
[ __ ] I couldn't I can't write that kind
of poetry man I mean if I did awesome
sorry we don't have any time for any
more questions we gotta get the next
group on actually can you be super quick
at the bad view
[Music]
you definitely lots of secret quarters
there's actually one in the b-roll a
little while ago with DES heads photos
but yeah secret passages and and finding
nooks and crannies and stuff is all
these these guys are huge wolf fans this
was a franchise that made them want to
make games so if you're a wolf fan you
will find lots of little oma jizz and
Easter eggs in here and to just rub your
face up against the way you probably
don't have a smear yourself all the way
don't know it's a it's slightly more
sophisticated than that now last
question are the portraits of Hitler in
every room there are not okay what sort
of Hitler's there one and how many
portraits of Hitler or in your woman's
side looking back to you okay yes
haven't really talked about the big h
guy been coy about it like yeah H dog we
don't talk about hdl-c happy times
that's the thank you so much for coming
on I really appreciate it Fred of
applause mr. P dies
get you Joker's up here
[Applause]
[Music]
you